In the previous lessons
Paco learned to install
a local development environment
and complete necessary steps
to register his application
in Google App Engine.
The last step left
to connect all the dots
consists in the unfolding or
deployment of his application.
Which basically means:
uploading the application
so that the Google App Engine
scalable infrastructure
begins to work.
Paco needs to design
an effective way
to update his application code
when it's in use.
He needs updates to be automatic
so as not to risk the chance
that only some files
get updated.
He also needs to think
of how to expand the changes
to the different active
http instances
How can Paco maintain
all of this consistent
at the same time his application
is serving applications?
For now, Paco's census
application consists in
only two files:
app.yaml and index.html
But the unfolding process
will be the same
as when the application
is larger.
One of the most important
details about unfolding
is that the process is done
within a transaction.
This means that...
either all the files
are successfully updated
or none of them are.
App Engine doesn't do
partial unfolding.
This way,
when the process is complete,
all files are deleted
and new copies of each one
are uploaded
from the local file.
If, for some reason,
the process fails,
App Engine automatically
uses the last version
successfully uploaded.
The app.yaml file determines
various important details
of the application
unfolding process.
For example...
the application field
defines the application
where the root code will be
uploaded and must correspond
to the identifier that Paco
created in the prior lesson.
The version field defines
the version of the application
that we're uploading.
This allows Paco
to have different versions
of the application
running simultaneously.
But it's important to remember
that each version
runs from
an independent instance,
so if we have two versions
of the application
our free trial
could run out in half the time.
Paco has various alternatives
to unfold the application
with the tools included
in the SDK.
To use
Google App Engine Launcher
he only has to click
on the deploy button.
To update using
app config,
Paco opens a window
to the terminal,
navigates the file
that contains the application
and executes
the following command.
Then he enters
his Google account ID.
This done, app config begins
to upload all the files
contained in
the 01 landingpage file
to Google App Engine.
If Paco doesn't want to write
his Google account password
directly in the terminal,
it's easier to execute
the command
with the option
minos minos or out2.
This allows him to authorize
appconfig
to make changes
to the registered application
in App Engine with just
a click on his navigator.
While running, app config
shows various messages
indicating the progress
of the update.
Paco will know if the process
was successfully completed
if he sees this message
in the terminal at the end.
This indicates that app config
has finished copying
all the files
to Google App Engine,
compiled the code and verified
that the application
is successfully
serving applications.
Paco can now
enter his application
by entering this address
in his navigator.
Once Paco's application
has been served
on Google App Engine, there
are various important details
that need to be taken
into account.
App Engine completes
additional optimizations.
For example,
his static files,
such as images,
CSS style pages
or Javascript files,
will be served
from a different structure.
Given that the application
executes from a sandbox,
it will not have information
about the hardware
or the operative system,
including the file system.
With Paco, we will learn
how to work with files
in the lesson about
Google cloud storage.
With app config, Paco can
also accomplish other tasks,
for example,
quickly download
the logs or records
for his application
executing this command.
These records
give him information
about how
his application is running
in terms of output.
It has a common apache format
and is chronologically ordered.
Make sure to check some options
and ways to execute
where you
can use app config.
You can obtain
a detailed description of these
writing this command
in the terminal.
In the following lessons,
we will see
how Paco uses app config
to complete tasks like:
uploading data to Datastore,
creating or modifying
programmed tasks,
or adjusting database indexes.
Don't let Paco
take of advantage of you
by unfolding your application
right now.
You will find that
Google App Engine allows you
to scale your applications
to millions of users
without configuring
a single application server.
I'll see you next time.
Keep programming!